hey Chris tell the do your do your
little rap on all the things you're said
that Ralph won't get to see CU I [__]
get this totally yeah this is stupid
stuff but um he really wanted to try
those apple VR glasses oh my God he was
lecturing me right up to the end about
how excited he was about the Apple VR
glasses so that um Ralph was always
talking always talking about he he loved
the 90s and if if you understand he was
so nostalgic for the '90s and he wanted
to write a book about the '90s and he
was always talking about that's going to
go on my book like a coffee table book
of the '90s and he wanted to write it um
I'm sad he won't get to see another
Batman movie I mean that was you know
one of the things he wanted to come over
and watch Batman Returns at my house and
I thought he was joking I thought it was
just him being you know his his flirty
self the way we'd flirt back and forth I
didn't know he actually wanted to come
over and watch a movie and it was only
when we were fighting he told me no I
was really hurt you didn't want me to
come over and watch a movie at your
place and of course I would have let him
come over and watch a movie at my place
I didn't give a [__] I cared so much
what he thought about me because I liked
Ralph so much just as a fan of the show
I mean he was like everything I wanted
to be he got under people's skin so I
thought it was really cool when we
became friends later in life and uh I I
think on the most important note I have
his HBO password and I'm wondering how
long will that work for you know M
really is the other woman because I used
to have that password and then one day
it stopped working one day it stopped
working and now I know what happened
yeah yeah it from you huh yeah wow I
just remembered a funny story real quick
I don't know if you remember this Jason
Alexa had just come out okay and we're
in Jason's basement and we find out that
Jason has an Alexa down there and it's
hooked up to his Amazon account so
whatever we say Alexa buy it's going to
start buying so Ralph and I just decide
we're going to start getting Alexa to
buy the worst [__] ever like stuff that
will incriminate Jason so Ralph Alexa
buy a shovel buying a shovel and I go
Alexa buy guide on how to kill my wife
buying guide on and I'd say something
and Ralph would try to top it dude they
were buying knives ropes
uh by top
soil I'm crying I've been
crying oh so great Ronnie you want to
say something there's Ron yeah man I
mean I was there from the beginning with
him too and I mean me and him never saw
eye to eye ever especially in the car I
mean Ralph and Ronnie was legendary I
never knew where I was going Ralph knew
the city and Ronnie would be driving me
and I never had to complain about Ronnie
Ronnie got me where I had to go Ralph
goes you realize Ronnie doesn't know
where he's going he'd whisper it to me
but whisper it loud enough he he would
Mumble it so I could hear it and and the
start com the steam would come out of my
head this is some tribute Ron but it's
so but it's so it's so true it's so
Ralph it's so Ralph the word for Ralph
is complicated he was a complicated guy
but he could be the nicest guy and the
biggest dick all in the same 60 seconds
but you know we talked a little bit
about it in the staff meeting this
morning and the thing that I said that's
really true is he was part of our family
like he was he was my family he was
family there was no better hang than
Ralph Cella we went out to dinner a
bunch of times we went to things a few
times a a and he was just great to hang
with didn't matter if it was with your
family with friends with famous people
he was just super comfortable and made
it a great time and you loved him for
that and when I got this news yesterday
it just you know it broke my heart I I I
just can't believe he's gone I I can't
believe Pablo you're on the air in Ohio
I I know that Ralph uh and uh Eric the
actor had you know a special bond and I
thoroughly enjoyed how Ralph always
signed off uh you know talking with you
by saying bye for now so that's right
that was it he left to go bye for now
thank you Ral bye for now bye bye for
now